якщо повномасштабного у торнані росії
україну україною Європи радикально
змінити свої ставлю не док-ти вив
росіян російські олігархи та основі
дневал і грос через європейські losev
кай і dp.ru ряди цех краєм на махаєте
прикритий ним кран
закидають щипок ще роботі на цю статтю
1 стак їх crying Великобританія
даси лондон бугульму лояльним до
російських брошів російським олігархом
легко було знає і банки риф юристів
добро до рифу готовий спів проти ти в
гаю за крима можна було легко побачимо
його це через складні схеми зуб чорними
трастом і за каченям та британською
владики річкову через Великобританію
проходить близько 100 мільярдів фунтів
стерлінгів на законне фінансування
якщо в торнані та росії в Україні
британському парламенті заговорила про
спідниці не законопроекту про економічніше
зло джинни винна суть ті воу складно ти
жити а багатіям і кіпру гнути прихвати
свої ставки в об'єднаному королівстві
засіки чай розкупили на руку масті
вибираючи проти вас стане 20 руки
Великобританія була солодким місцем для
грудних російською грушею росіян та
приїжджала сюди йди своїм та дахи моїм
подібне до верховенства закону тут і їм
подавай ще них тонни старий джон
випробувань
розум і з білим браузером і вдома на
дон сквер одну з найбільших поганих
лондон у фешенебельному районі був і
гравію самі ст ще називають червону you
площею я таким на квартира тут
кошт у японок 20 мільйонів євро і ніхто
не намагай охта справжній владних за
каченям і містпортом корупції та
російські олігархи під'їзди не з
путіним астані мороком і ян го ствола мій
ж 2 мільярди євро вийшов руху містера
шоу ліпить віконниці компанії трасту його for
немає разів ти nominal не особливо-то duggar у
його особи і всесвіту сторони проти
рахунок за кущ це справжнє право
влади на темні руки
лондон град також back to page of
називатися столицею Великобританії через
тисячу відразу в джамалу багатих росіян
і далеко не всі з них за рублі youth
собі на жити від чесну про цію
британський парламент наріжте взявся за
закон за іклами прибирання ти куртин
іпотеку роше з Росії то порівнюють і
складні структури владності алекс лиш
перший кроку боротьбі з вимиванням
посмажити експерти
1 лиж та законодавства за дістати його
нам по ви ну реально протити а ціни
активно на лижний машинах про фінансово
адже ти вона мені буваєте наступна
національне агентство боротьби з краще
несе немає фінансується проти фонду
city ​​new томуза раз на спідниці блищу в
права шкоди театр та молитви видно та
фенотипу мене від і запитаємо famous
адаптацією на сам карет я хотів би ще
сто олігархи по трапу на дошці санки та
їх не моє але була заморожена подругою я
хотів би ще було виявлено і після teu
замороженої їх не активі і потріть я
хотів би ще pussy російські банки анни
шекелі кешбек було вигляд ключі не битися з
тієї ми свіфт ще одна країна Європи яко
славою зі своїм нейтральним статусом
також акти внеш здобувши забрати намисто
відмиванням грошей і російських олігархів
швейцарські тюр їх одна з найду гаях
місцю свиті на вас the new jersey shore
з російських олігархів ники заливка та
вкладають сюди свої гросе рудольф і
mercalli збу у праведним банкірам у
тюркскому банку юліус б весь хід nevian
один з наприклад ні іскри таки в цех
фінансових інститутів та відомі як
інформатор wikileaks і назвати
зберігаються в
банку вас є захищаючи олігархи наш
девіз та гори закон проти лікарень та ряд
це суду до органу не харчується цілісне
важливий вишень був швейцарії в темпі
вальсу що від алана cliven її росії
проти України на швейцарію спочив і
згаснуть з ну ти і нч україни заходу а
б влада краї треба покращилася пеклі
санкційний заходимо в результаті burn
Петро i move санкції мовляв російські
олігархи вершинам атома доступу до своїх
активі фу швейцарії ельмар мало що
ванни скептично
захоплювалася
виданих йому дістати почався ще в
боротьбі зі своєю кішкою вищими попит на
кого вони схожі не слухай давні
традиції у швейцарії сцен означає
практичний вас немає москву ці зуби і про
зростатиме на соломонових островах
обговорити відставних компанія загинути
відвозить давно ти до кого нас прохання
накласти простіше
асоціація швейцарських банки риф вид
кидається значення з'являються ще санкції
може, буду добрим вони повну світу і
важливо його хіба ще немає санкції зум
обв'язувати банку за видами ляд та владу
проросійських клієнтів банки в скатаем
знайти Миколи на буваючи абсолютну на
і може спливає і юргіс не зубів я за
не сюди на дані інформації сосу suite і
нинішніх самі приховані парі сен санса
старий чохол російські газпромбанк то
ощадбанк представляється твоєю до них
тут у тюрків у звір на не витися йти за
дозволяючи краї нам з таким як негайно
neri karra ніші купава це через них
російську на авто і газ цього таке лихо
ліберж приховані до швейцарського суспільства
ощадбанк кутюр їх у зачинивши звело рік
епта у пости в залізини вік нах робота
6 протестів на урядова організація
паблік і вже давно про таке російські
банки від і порт затверджують рахунки банки
вигляді краю тварюки шалену роль vine хіба
я за нею москвою за списком відвернуся
надзвичайна багом штучну до школи
і коси путіна вин розруха ванна не з
самого початку і пропусків читайте
простіше за найм і продовжу в цьому
підходу ти можу форуму про мільярд
доларів щебеню в сімдесят дві сотки
п'єха їх є швейцарських торгових
майданчики
один з центрів міжбанківської складаються з
вид знаходиться пару частиною лихом на
розживін знаходите піт посил іншу харону
вчилися по бою ви не диверсії збоку русі
і розум стем рудольф ельмар не думаючи ще
повний вигляд ключі не русь з'явиться буду
настей кадром чи відмінним росія
жителі мою критику і знову цікавіше
способами ти цінно при кліпси рази роки
був середньо mesh компанії ми банківський
холдинг та за допомогу обхідних торговельних
повії і бартерних у варіанті
багату і на роті забувати ще сьогодні
чари санкцій бізнес навколо платіжних
операцій стали звикла вишен але
клопіт його року ще один дружно до
російського бізнесу європейської околиці
відро угу воланів торг на неросійських
військ в Україну горішками майна олігархію
а бути більше тед позов на президента
Росії Володимира Путіна Італія почала
конфіскований у це super yacht це їм
соски шниру хамити у мільярдерів з
сантин їх списку харчувалися до влади
конфіскувала яхт це вілли на суму
ні 143 мільйони євро вела російських
олігархи в знаходите а ми зливи трохи
місцях тоскана сардинія Юрій зникла
береш це озеру комо
італійської фінансово поліція закупила в
порту sanremo супер яхту я канал і джуді
винним пшонку вона ближча на моду
путіна олігарху конфіскував це корж з
10 5 метрову яхту вдм російського
мільярдера олексія мордашова судно мої
сісти апартаменти і відтінюється в 65
мільйонів євро і напевно найбільшої улову
італійського полити її арешт маху яхти
російського олігарха андрея мельниченка
яхта була пришвартована біля порту місця
трієст тебе супер яхта поважаєте одні нею
з найбільших приватних вітрильних та
моторних яхт у свиті 143 метри за
вдовиною і 25 метрів за флешкою, а її
vortice сахайя близько 500 мільйонів євро
горішками та націях олігархи pitbull & cie
після супроводу санте з 9 б розряду
списку персональних санкцій з дугал та
160 осіп 14 знаєш олігархи до
бізнесмени а також члени їх нік сімей
ришта депутати раді федерації столітті
дізнався і так дзвони днр і лнр а чого ти
а не євросоюзу проводивши четвертий пакет
санкцій за провину Росії проти України
сантино вас піску внесла ще 15
фізичних та дев'ятьма різних осип за
рідних російський олігарх роман
абрамович
гендиректор рособоронекспорту Олександр
міхєєв та гендиректор першого каналу
російського т.п. костян terms